okay hello everyone we are doing a
working session here talking about
multi-computation
and um its relationship to Wolfram
language
so uh
let's start off with Nick talking about
pattern matching experiments
um
so as I understand this
um
these are functions that dive into the
innards of pattern matching basically
well not truly they're completely
separate system
they just to be implementing all the
pattern Primitives
do they do it buglessly I mean do you
know have you run the tests the pattern
matcher tests on them and things
okay well some of them but they I just
have a plan to again implement it from
scratch a little bit different in a
different way
because I need some laziness for it to
work how I want it to
okay but so let's understand what this
is and I'm surprised if we're talking
about this kind of language design that
we don't have Christopher and folks like
that here
um
maybe uh
I mean if we're going to talk about this
can we should we could we please ping
Christopher yeah right now
um
okay
but net can you explain the the purpose
of these functions which I think I
understand but can you try to explain
that again
well the purpose is yeah the first the
first purpose is just for me to
understand how patterns work that's the
first goal and the second goal is just
to make it a little bit more informative
each pattern matching procedure in the
language comes with additional
information what actually happens with
some kind of intermediate object
right take part and substitution
okay but but so
the question here is
um
uh you know so there should be a flow in
which replace for example becomes a
two-step process where first it finds
the bindings and then it applies them is
that is that correct
well yeah even a little bit more on that
not the just bindings just having
procedure just that finds Bindings that
was my first implementation but it's not
enough because this intermediate object
has have to have more information than
just symbol bindings yeah right
it has to know which part of the
expression
was matched to this is that correct yeah
each basically each button you have a
button and you know position which
button object there and you know even if
this never even if it doesn't consist
any symbol there that you want to bind
it into you still want to know where
what is this pattern binds to like blank
blank that it bound to 137 or something
yeah exactly yeah
okay and do you deal with with orderless
functions and things like that
that's right through
to get that flat orderless one identity
attributes to work to
is there an obvious reason why you don't
try and put this into the I mean in
other words if you were looking at the
internal code
maybe the internal code is already doing
a bunch of this stuff and it's just a
question of using those internal
functions in an appropriate way
have you considered that possibility
or I've looked at it slightly already
it doesn't look like it's doing
something like that there's some idea of
much boxes that I I think
oh gosh those are my those were mine
that's from 1987. yeah
yeah okay
um I think that was almost a pun this
idea of a matchbox but yeah go ahead
obviously I don't know yet how it works
but I think it's doing
it's much more complicated way than I
wanted to do it
fair enough
but if you can do it in a way that is
uh you know correct
that's quite interesting I mean in it's
quite interesting for other purposes
like the compiler and so on I would
think
because if your thing is top level code
that does this
it's not obvious it couldn't do it on
Expo structs for example
sure
yeah yeah it can work anymore expression
right but the Expo struct is the
internal representation so in other
words if your code ran on the express
truck my understanding is if your code
could be compiled we would have a
compiled version of the pattern match up
yeah maybe well it doesn't have to be an
expert struct so because I have it's
like I'm trying to
take good care of actually where what
expression evaluates and what not it's
like right now I just have a bunch of
unrelated hold or arguments
inappropriate places
necessarily
okay but so so there are really two this
is a dual use thing because it's really
something where
um it's both relevant for us to
sort of see how to do well you're going
to talk about multi-evaluates in a
moment but this is what what you have
here
if I understand correctly
is the raw material that will be needed
to take pattern matching multi is that
correct
well that would certainly help yeah
I already said that the multi is just
replace list
but this is just replace with more
information
right but I mean this allows one to for
example get causal graphs
and and things like that whereas pure
replace list does not
yeah I have a way to Traverse the
matching departure matcher differently
with different Traverse holders
that's a good point too
and the other thing it will allow is
they're improving stuff
because it will allow you will have the
trace of what sequence of pattern
matchings actually took place to get
from from you know X to Y correct
yeah
yep so I mean the representation that
you have of
the matching and replacement process
should be compared to the representation
that find equational proof generates
well yeah basically yes it is the same
thing it's just proof
is is also have Bindings that go in both
directions so it's a little bit more
General than that right now pattern
matching is only single directional
button matcher
so the generalization would be to make
it bi-directional and that will
correspond to a proof
why is it necessary why don't you just
take every Rule and replace it and and
make two copies of it
uh what do you mean well to make it
bi-directional just have a goes to B and
B goes to a both B rules in the
collection of rules
no by bi-directional I mean that right
now I pattern my patterns against
expressions
but in One Direction I wanna match
patterns against patterns so if I have a
pattern objects like Alternatives in the
expression I want to match it against
like a different direction okay fine so
that that is the two-way rule type um
um it's not quite two-way rule two way
rule it's just two rules
separately
but when you have like just a button and
another button and you want a pattern
matching in both ways like finding
unification most general unifier or
whatever you want to call it this is a
bi-directional machine
right
I mean right now
you know even
I mean notationally
we've got this idea
you know you can write x blank I don't
know x blank y
whatever two-way rule
you know
y blank
x blank or something is that correct
that's a meaningful thing to write
uh well I'm not sure about that
I mean
what I'm saying is go ahead you have
blank on one side double blank all right
double blanks okay forget my double
blanks
okay okay so I mean then
the basic point is that
we're used to the idea Okay so we've got
several things that need to plug into
this for example find equational proof
does not accept things in this form does
it
yeah in exactly this terminal but it's
equivalent form I know it's an
equivalent form but I mean even even to
convert even having conversion functions
between f of x y
you know equals equals F of y x
and the pattern form of that seems like
it will be a useful thing to have
yeah maybe with an explicit quantifier
like for all in this case
yeah right fine
you know between between I I think that
seems useful to be able to convert
between the pattern form and the
algebraic form
seems sensible I mean and then
then what you have here
is let me just see what what um
so let's see pattern substitutions what
does that do
well that will produce this
Giant and formatted currently object
my God
can I um can I make that pretty printed
slightly what can I do to make it well
if you get full form patterns right now
I get will get rid of this context
the bucktick Wolfram Patrick's party
just just get this context
okay
so this is like the outer head is a sum
so it means like every element in that
sum is a
separate thing that can be matched so if
you want a single match you can just
take the first one and ignore all the
rest
and if it's the product you have too
much of them all the elements have a
product
yep and if it's a part substitution it's
something like a hierarchical structure
that contains an actual part or and and
the potential sub pattern
so we can recover the information okay
um
see where am I putting this it's
research multi-computation uh Kristen
where am I putting this SW yes yeah
okay so this is a representation of
uh
what
this is this
you could derive from this the
multi-match for this is that correct
by multi-match I mean all possible
matchings yeah like bindings
that's why yeah separate function that
just applies to this object and gets all
the bindings
and
go ahead and then you know this object
could be lazy that's what I'm gonna do
next second right now it's just I have a
third agreement pattern substitutions
and it will try to like to make a few to
do with to do it efficiently and to
extract just as many as you want but it
I think it should be shouldn't have this
argument to just be lazy
generator that I can just travels
however I want
right
okay but but how do you access that to
say what traversal you want
well there's a natural trigger so it's
like someone wants to go like bread
first
and product is the other way around
it's super similar to just like if you
have a polynomial
if you have X Plus y
times h plus b anyone expanded so what
what would be the order of your
individual terms this is analogous to
that you have a sum and a product and
even expand it and just take some number
of terms from the expansion
right
which would correspond to a particular
choice
of bindings is that correct
yeah each individual is a particular
choice of bindings but each term in the
sum is a possible binding
that has whose product elements the
elements of the product the monomials so
to speak correspond to the particular
bindings of particular variables
that correct
yeah if it's already an expanded form
that you have just sum of products and
yeah but product also can contain a sum
and some disk some can container I get
it I get it so I mean it really is as
you say much like polynomials yeah
and so so I mean essentially this is an
algebra matching algebra
so how do we
think about I mean
I see so
is there a graphical representation of
this matching algebra
hmm
I mean some is like parallel parts
somehow product
it's not really sequential
um
okay
it is kind of like a tree
with sub trees
for the inner sums
yeah
that that paralyzes that each sum
paralyzes each product
is
sort of sequentially going down is that
right
so that as you Traverse you're
ultimately your ultimate match
is kind of the leaves
is the pause through this tree is that
correct
yeah yeah the matching should find the
leaves
and they have substitutional value so
it's my leaf expression
just that just holds the actual parts of
an expression that you imagine against
mm-hmm
well
maybe you could try drawing those trees
it might be it might be Illuminating and
and that tree
will in turn have some relationship to
the expression tree won't it
I mean it's some kind of
am I making sense
and well
I don't know I don't know what is this I
don't think there is a variation to the
expression the immediate one okay
okay but anyway so that then all right
so there's a representation of the
matching algebra
and
from the matching algebra you can
extract certain things like a particular
set of substitution bindings for a
particular path
a particular sort of you know
monomial effectively in the matching and
the matching ball in our mail
correct
right yeah
like the simplest example would be
substitution bindings already have like
a third argument how many you want to
extract it but so if it were a generator
it would actually Traverse it
efficiently and just extract as much as
only the ones that you want
the first right
but this is the full multi-way version
of substitution bindings this is
generating all of them yeah correct
yeah
okay
so in a sense
just like we have that evaluation graph
Let's see we I mean the thing we're
talking about over here is a matching
graph
and then
you know there's also a multi-way
matching graph
ICS I'm not sure why it's a graph
okay but I bet this is a graph because
there are lots of shared pieces there
I think
well okay but but in any case so the
thing that
the thing that you're going to be able
to do from this
okay my question would be the proof
function
from find equational proof what's the
relationship of that to what you have
here
sort of
so the proof function
takes in
a bunch of
lemas
and just it runs them on your initial
actions and try to come up with the
hypothesis
something I'm not sure
it's not not there is no immediate
connection again well okay so so but
look look
what you do when you're
you know a proof
is a sequence of rule applications
where you know where they're getting
applied
is that a fair characterization
yeah yeah in this sincerely this is also
kind of a bunch of instructions
I have it like in a separate function
here in the packet called substitution
apply it's it's if you
feed this object that is written by
pattern substitution and
and then and the pattern that you
generated it from the goal is that it
should
recover the expression back
okay which to me sounds awfully like
proof function
you you've got
a set of replacements
and you're claiming that given those
replacements
you will recover the tautology basically
yeah you just replace all the pattern
Primitives with some expression and the
goal is to recover the expression back
yeah
okay
well so the next steps for this
uh what what are the next steps for this
section here
the next step is to make it lazy
generators
and I'm going kind of marinating that
idea still
I recovering also reviewing my lazy
packet and that
polls that we have at some school also
related
sorry which sounds cool what I think
some student I think it was Athena
um
constricting structures data structures
you should be in touch with her I think
she's interested in exploring this
further
yeah
um obviously got the same kind of idea
with cons list and constraint it has the
same name
oh really okay
um
okay we're good to to make contact with
her about that
um
maybe maybe um
Kristen could could make sure that
happens yeah I'll make sure that happens
and connect to you
yeah
um
okay
so
all right so I'm I'm still trying to
understand so the suite of functions
that we're going to have here is
basically it is the
more
you know more atomized version of
pattern matching
so it is pattern substitutions
it is a this matching algebra type thing
and then it is processors of this
matching algebra is that correct and
then there is also a need to essentially
foliate traversal order whatever you
call it
the expressions in the matching algebra
is that correct so you decide which
match you actually want to use
yeah
if that like python substitution would
return some kind of lazy tree then
you're just gonna be a way to feed it at
reversal road that we already have
different Notions of those and and
recover
the like individual matchings
right
now we don't have lazy trees do we
I mean you you need to build a lazy tree
yeah
okay at least the trees are essential
that the structures that should be there
which was the project
by Athena and I also have some the same
implementation
okay so so there's a separate
okay so lazy structures
so I think in our language that will be
called delayed list or something
liked it
the late
maybe it's like hold this because it's
essentially just some
new head with hold
or hold the rest
held list Maybe
or delayed okay but so
or even less delayed I don't know since
we have set delayed not that anybody
knows it's called that but that's what
colon equals is
yeah
right
I mean you know list delayed seems like
not completely stupid as a possible name
but so then you've got also the notion
of a tree delayed
yeah
uses the list the way it doesn't it's as
its children
kinda
okay so listen delayed supports certain
kinds of accessories like like part
numbers and things parts and so on is
that correct
yeah you have to like the whole purpose
of the whole
difficulty in the whole implementation
of this list device thing is just coming
up with the app files that work with it
for different lists functions like
partitions
especially and make it parallel
particular parallel map for the lazy
Lister also
the most trick if you can that's it
cool
well anyway so
so
um
Ethan on a live stream is asking about
compatibility of lists delayed which is
again an interesting question
but okay so you are
you are basically backing into
implementing things like list delayed
and then
and that's a data structure that you
want to use for this matching tree
yeah
which then still has these Primitives in
it
that represent sort of granular
components of the matching process
like substitution sum and substitution
product I mean I I'm just the thing
that's driving me crazy about this is
they are so similar to type summon type
product
oh yeah it's the same kind of
category you have products and cool
products
I mean
okay
but then okay given a tree delayed
then there would be something like tree
map
with a certain traversal order
treat of us Lord Arab blah and that
would give us and and one of those one
of those is the traditional okay
question
how do we get and this is a tree
question for Ian
how do we get
the first element in a certain traversal
order out of a tree
so you could list all of the sub trees
in a given order
but we don't have kind of inefficient so
part extraction
um
so so how would I what will be the way
of doing that listing the subtrees and a
certain to a Slaughter
tree level
of the tree comma all
comma tree traversal order whatever
okay how do I get the first
how do I get the what's that
just take part one of that list
anyway I don't know it's not I I just
want to get the visit order
no I want what do I want to get I want
to get the first element that I get I
guess I want to get the first leaf that
will be the thing for Nick the first
leaf with that traversal order
maybe a buff from a root note to the
leaf yes okay
how would I get that here
seems like there needs to be another
utility for trees maybe maybe there's
something Nick could build
um
okay
so I'm not sure what you're asking for
like you want you want the path in that
list I want two eight six
because why do I want that I want that
because that's what our pattern matcher
actually does
see what I'm saying it's taking the
first match
in a depth first traversal
of the match tree
is that that's correct right Nick it's
the first match of the first traversal
of the match tree
yeah it should be yeah
it's like 286 is like a product or just
a much in your sequence
right
okay well look it seems to me there are
things you could do where you can
actually make this explicitly as a tree
and then we can maybe understand a
little
better
okay let's let's move on unless you want
to say more about this section we're
going to run out of time so I want to
talk things about this section
um how are there more than one bindings
for shortest
shouldn't there be a unique match
because it's a replace list basically
you should the difference where you put
the shot is just defines how they're
ordered so it's like the difference
between first and second shortness it's
only the order of those bindings
that's an interesting claim I mean the
shortest is not pruning the tree
that's what that's what you're saying
here shortest is merely reordering and
not and not pruning the tree
whereas Ian is saying why isn't it
pruning the tree
is just to decide how how I would
Traverse it
well but I mean the shortest sequence
that matches blank should just be a
single element
I don't see how short this could match a
sequence of two or more things in this
case
yeah I mean without a slash semi or
something like that that's annotating
this all of these matches could never be
realized correct Nick
yeah if you just ask for a first one
there shouldn't be even considered
I know but what Ian is saying is given
the semantics of shortest
okay so I don't know where the replace
list I mean we can we can clearly
determine that if we say
you know replace list
I had no idea well you're right Nick
so Ian does that surprise you it
surprises me
yeah I don't understand that
nor do I
I mean it's a it's a different semantics
from shortest than the one I thought it
was using and I think we okay we need to
dive into this understand that but
that's okay
okay is this what we were looking at
already last time
yes
yep
okay but where did we want to go with
this
this is
I mean
this is the multi-way
Trace graph correct
that we have here
yeah
what's the relationship okay
and so then
I mean
graph this is using Trace graph
to visualize the things that actually
call the evaluator
[Music]
everything else is
uh
like replace list with rules
yeah well the issue is as we show the
breakdown of how a computation happens
how broken down do we want to go
I personally would like just some
a very interactive thing that you can
just
like just select what piece of part of
your expression you want to emulate and
move this graph not generated like from
scratch with all possible directions I
actually choose
just interactive emulator
well see if you can build something
I mean
I think that's one thing I think I'll be
really good but I think another thing
is understanding the multi-way version
because you know one of the big purposes
here
is to see how to make you know again I'm
looking for things like find replace
path
you know how does that get represented
you know we've got this this fully you
know everything multi-way thing
and then we've got you know find replace
path that is finding particular paths in
here
am I am I right or actually find replace
path is finding paths and this thing
over here which is not the evaluator but
rather the substituter
correct
and yeah
did you build something is this Choice
interactive something you built no it's
not mine
so you invite Richard
it's an old thing already
okay isn't that where it can also Peak
the like different parts and different
results if it's uh
like a price list ambiguity which
gosh I've never used this
this is cool
yeah I mean I think this is cool but I
think it needs more you know it needs
more of a of a map showing you where you
are in the whole graph I think
right
oh no there's a system function Trace
dialogue
oh that's right this may be using I'm
not sure
but look I couldn't I how do I get out
of this
help
anybody have any idea how to get out of
this
okay
I should have closed this notebook
until it's finished thank you yes
I noticed that now
oh gosh I realized I was running some
big jobs overnight I hope this doesn't
help
any anybody got any idea maybe somebody
could ask Rick Hannigan how you get out
of this
if
um
Kristen could could uh message him yeah
I'm asked him right now
okay
okay so Nick are we
these things here
which of these are
is this from my notes
Justin yeah okay all right so can you
come up with your version of this
because I don't think you agree with
quite all of these functions right
well some of them are just unrelated to
the thing I had done the most related is
the detailed replace I think
okay button rules
okay
okay but the thing we need to do here is
we've got certain things like we we know
we we want to have you know conversions
between these forms we know I mean let's
just try and start making something
that's a production type thing that is
at the very least
I mean even things like your you know
applying by substitution things like
that we need to have those functions
right
I also think it's a really much replace
thing that does it
okay fine but but you know what we're
trying to do is is get those to the
point where they can actually be built
in functions
yeah that's tricky yeah
which means all of those things have to
fit together and our goal
in the larger scale
is
you know as we have other applications
of multi-computation and as we want
different kinds of observers and things
like this but you know just like
the good news was in in doing the
mathematics project we could pretty much
leverage existing token event graph and
Nest graph tagged and so on things for
that project we didn't have to build
custom new multi-computational functions
mostly
at least that's my recollection of it
the goal is and again again one of our
output goals is multi-way graph needs to
be replaced by cleaner better
you know built-inable functions so to
speak does that make sense
are you do you mean multi-waste system
that's what I mean it's probably very
nice way graph
it's more not not a rebuilding of it but
uh like completely thinking how to make
it more concise yes
yes
just divide it into more approachable
elements like we don't have to have some
many properties of it exactly
we make
graphs just States graph with tags it's
like the whole output of a multi-way
system for any kind of system that I
want it's just some kind of version of a
nice graph with very convenient tags
that they can use for extracting causal
information exactly exactly that's what
we want to have
and and then we'll have a function
bronchial graphs or something that goes
from that and finds you know and and
gets that piece and so on I think the
goal should be
okay that
you know
the goal is for 13-2 to see what we can
do to actually put multi-computation
functions into the language
because I think we're we're stable
enough on a bunch of these things that
we can start to do that
now I think that that as we try and
merge essentially the quantum gravity
story the um uh you know the spatial
information with the branchial
information that's where things like
local multi-race systems and all those
kinds of things come in and you know
that that is more complicated but I
think we need to try and see how we are
doing existing stuff you know in a in a
way that can actually fit into the
language and that's I think what we
should aim for
well how about just uh we firstly update
nesgraph to be essentially an S graph
tag with some yeah it'll be useful yeah
and then update
like all kind of systems functions like
so automata substitution system tuner
machine things instead of just applying
a state the point to a state and get the
final state it also has some in
additional information of causality
I think that would be enough and if if
you use this kind of function with this
Dash graph tag and it will tag with this
additional information you can extract
cosmographs from it why don't you see if
you can figure out that design
okay and remember with Netcraft when we
talked about that last time right and
hopefully there are notes from that we
talked about all these things about
traversal orders and termination
conditions and so on right
because that's what we need for this
makes sense
yeah okay
well I mean that's what we need it's
kind of complicated and I think that's
going to require you know this is a
complicated piece of design right and
it's going to require a whole bunch more
design meetings to straighten it out but
I think you know your
you know the more you can build
prototypes of these things or proposed
final versions the better you know so
that we actually start homing in on what
does it really look like
um
first I need to figure out patterns
yeah whatever at once
yeah I understand I understand but but I
think we have to just have make sure we
know the path here that gets us to
things like find replace path and all
those kinds of things that so that
because that's you know what we're
getting is you're figuring out patterns
you've got this matching algebra you've
got that gives us the patterns have a
certain multi-way-ness to them
and
uh
yeah I think that that's that's what
we're doing here all right we should we
should probably wrap up for now here
so to be continued anybody any anything
else for lost comments here
oh okay see you all soon
bye